[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24 le
Qatar a-t-il influé sur les politiques
de l'Union européenne voilà la question
qui se pose après les arrestations de 6
personnes à Bruxelles 4 d'entre elles
ont été écrouées et va Kylie la
vice-présidente du Parlement européen et
lui socialiste grec Francesco Giorgi un
assistant parlementaire qui est aussi
son compagnon pierre Antonio Panzeri
ancien euro député social-démocrate
italiens et président de l'ONG fight
impunity et Nicolas figa thalamanca lui
dirigeant de l'ongis without justice au
cours des perquisitions la police a mis
la main sur plus de 600 000 euros en
liquide le Parti socialiste grec a exclu
et va Kylie la présidente du Parlement
européen Roberta mezzola a suspendu tous
ses pouvoirs et lance une enquête
interne ces soupçons de corruption sont
très graves à estimer ursulafanderlion
ils sont bien sûr un choc pour les
institutions européenne en pleine partie
de bras de fer avec la Hongrie de Victor
Hormann accusé justement de corruption
alors le Qatar a-t-il versé de l'argent
à évacue Kylie et à trois autres
personnes pour influer sur leur décision
jusqu'où ira cette affaire quel est son
impact sur les institutions européennes
alors que la Commission gèle les fonds
européens destinés à la Hongrie parce
qu'elle ne lutte pas suffisamment contre
la corruption les institutions
européennes doivent-elles créer des
garde-fous voilà toutes les questions
que l'on va poser à nos invités j'ai le
plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés Patrick
martin-genier bonsoir vous êtes
enseignants à Sciences Po et spécialiste
des questions européennes bienvenue à
vous dans le débat David rigoloz est
avec nous bonsoir vous êtes rédacteur en
chef de la revue Orient à stratégique le
livre consacré à l'Iran la République
islamique d'Iran en crise systémique
chercheur également à l'Institut
français d'analyse stratégiques et
chercheurs associés à l'Iris bienvenue à
vous nous avons également par Skype de
Strasbourg Véronique Trillet le bonsoir
vous êtes heureux députés réunion Europe
merci d'être avec nous
et puis également duplex de Strasbourg
Manon Aubry euro député la France
insoumise bonsoir à vous et bienvenue
dans le débat
bonsoir
six personnes interpellé une
vice-présidente écrouée une onde de choc
bien sûr au sein du Parlement européen
l'affaire éclabousse littéralement les
institutions européennes avant dans des
battre on fait un point en images
ce lundi au Parlement européen les mines
sont graves et embarrassées à la hauteur
des faits reprochés à sa vice-présidente
ce sont des nouvelles très inquiétantes
très très inquiétantes
une enquête de police et de justice sont
en cours nous devons suivre ce qui en
ressort
vous comprenez bien qu'il s'agit
d'accusation très grave très grave
la vice-présidente du Parlement européen
et trois autres personnes parmi
lesquelles un ancien élu européen
italien sont désormais en prison une
enquête de la justice belge est en cours
elle porte sur des soupçons de
versements effectués par le Qatar pour
influencer des décisions au sein de
l'institution selon une source
judiciaire des sacs de billets ont été
trouvés dans l'appartement des
vacaillies
cela va bien au-delà de ce qui s'est
passé dans ce cas très spécifique il
s'agit vraiment de la réputation d'une
institution démocratique de la confiance
de nos concitoyens
l'affaire éclatant plein Mondial de
football au Qatar pointé du doigt par
les ONG pour son piètre bilan en matière
de respect des droits de l'homme en
particulier des travailleurs engagés
pour construire les sites de la Coupe du
monde en novembre dernier évacueillait
avait surpris vantant les réformes
entreprises par le Qatar à la tribune du
Parlement européen
j'ai été la seule à dire que le Qatar
est un leader en matière de droit du
travail avec l'abolition du système de
la kafala l'introduction du salaire
minimum alors que même les entreprises
européennes ont du mal à respecter ses
lois une réunion des présidents de
groupe parlementaires se tient ce lundi
sur le sujet à la demande de la
présidente du Parlement européen Robert
pametzola
qui s'est exprimé il y a quelques
instants
ne se manifeste pas soyez assurés
qu'elles sont bien présentes ainsi que
ma détermination pour que cette
assemblée se renforce
ne vous méprenez pas chers collègues le
Parlement européen est attaqué
européenne est sous le feu des attaques
et nos sociétés démocratiques ouvertes
et libres sont prises pour cible le
Parlement européen est attaqué à dit
donc Roberta mezzola Manon Aubry vous
aviez dit vous avez dit que vous aviez
des soupçons au moment du vote de la
résolution sur le Qatar vous soupçonniez
une affaire de corruption
en réalité ça faisait déjà plus d'un an
qu'avec mon groupe de la Gauche au
Parlement européen en se battait pour
avoir une résolution et en
positionnement très clair de notre
Parlement sur les graves violations des
droits humains qui se déroulaient pour
l'organisation de cette Coupe du Monde
au Qatar pendant un an j'ai vu
l'opposition claire et manifeste du
groupe socialiste et du groupe de la
droite le groupe PPE et puis à la
dernière session plénière c'est là où
les soupçons ont été bien davantage
étayés nous sommes parvenus à une courte
majorité à obtenir cette résolution et
pendant les négociations qui se
déroulent ici à huis clos au Parlement
européen pendant ces négociations
auxquelles je représentais mon groupe en
réalité il était clair que certains
groupes voulaient à tout prix défendre
les intérêts du Qatar il était possible
de dénoncer le rôle de la FIFA mais en
revanche il ne fallait absolument pas
toucher la responsabilité du Qatar dans
l'évaluation des droits humains et en
revanche il fallait évidemment
saluer les bonnes relations
diplomatiques entre l'Union européenne
et le les soi-disant efforts qu'aurait
fait le Qatar en matière de droit du
travail même parler du rôle que le Qatar
jouait dans l'approvisionnement
énergétique ce qui voulait dire quelque
chose de la mission qui était confié
assez groupe un tel point qu'en effet je
suis sorti ce qui m'est jamais arrivé
depuis que je participe à des
négociations ici je suis sortie de ces
négociations me posant la question de si
le Qatar avait interféré ou participer
d'une manière ou d'une autre assez
négociations dont je ne pensais pas si
bien dire et je crois qu'à la lumière de
ce scandale de corruption on en a
désormais en partie la réponse Véronique
trilet Lenoir votre réaction à ce que
vient de dire justement Manon Aubry vous
aussi vous aviez éventuellement des
doutes vous avez été surprise
je voudrais commencer par dire que je
partage la consternation et le mélange
de tristesse et de colère qui ont été
exprimées par la présidente du Parlement
non moi je n'avais pas assez doute pour
la raison probablement que contrairement
à Madame AUBRY je ne suis pas impliquée
dans des commissions qui parlent
d'affaires étrangères ou d'ingérence je
m'occupe des sujets de santé au
Parlement européen et je dois avouer que
je n'avais pas
pressenti ce qui aggrave probablement ma
surprise et ma colère David Rigoulet
rose le doigt le Qatar ni tout
implication est-ce que ce qu'on entend
dire dans cette enquête fait partie d'un
certain nombre de pratiques côté
cathares c'est toujours le problème
effectivement des ce qu'on appelle les
stratégies d'influence à partir du
moment où il y a des gros enjeux et
beaucoup d'argent
il y a forcément des interrogations qui
peuvent qui peuvent s'élever c'est pas
propre d'ailleurs au Qatar ça vaut pour
toutes les questions de lobbying au
niveau européen
on l'a vu avec des affaires comme la
chimie les médicaments mais
effectivement il y a un problème
d'encadrement et là en l'occurrence
c'est quand même une affaire
particulièrement douloureuse pour le
Parlement parce que d'après le juge
Michel cllaise en charge de la faire moi
je me prononcerai pas évidemment sur la
procédure judiciaire il est évoqué une
corruption et un blanchiment en bande
organisé donc c'est quand même avec
flagrance donc c'est c'est effectivement
ça explique le choc que à qui
représenter les révélations qui qui ont
eu lieu on est sur un registre quand
même très particulier c'est pas
uniquement une stratégie d'influence
comme il peut y avoir par le biais de
lobbying tout à fait j'allais dire
reconnu publiquement etc donc il y a
effectivement c'est un choc et c'est
d'autant plus un choc que le sujet est
éminemment sensible on est dans le
contexte du Mondial on est dans le
contexte de la crise énergétique avec la
question du gaz
donc tout ça évidemment donne un
ensemble particulièrement préoccupants
Manon Brias que la vie présidente et
vacaely doit démissionner de son mandat
et pas seulement être suspendu là on a
vu que c'est bien ont également été
gelés
et c'est une évidence elle doit
démissionner de son poste de vie
président pour commencer je suis atterré
du fait que ici on a eu une réunion
entre président de groupe un peu plus
tôt dans l'après-midi et on doit en fait
actionner ce que ce qui est l'article 21
dans les règles du Parlement européen et
c'est à nous de solliciter la suspension
de ses fonctions alors que je ne
comprends même pas pourquoi y compris
son groupe ne lui a pas demandé très
clairement à la fois de démissionner de
son poste de vice-présidente mais plus
largement de démissionner de son mandat
de Parlement européen elle n'a
évidemment pu la confiance de personnes
pour représenter qui que ce soit ici si
c'était le Qatar de toute évidence mais
je vais au delà il s'agit là d'une
eurodéputée d'autres sont dans le viseur
je pense qu'il va falloir une commission
d'enquête pour faire toute la lumière
sur les défaillances institutionnelles
au sein du Parlement européen qui ont
permis ce type de pratique et
considérablement renforcer les règles
éthiques au sein des institutions
européennes on en appelle depuis le au
début de notre mandat ici avec notre
groupe de la Gauche à une la création
d'une autorité éthique indépendante je
crois que ce scandale le rappelle
urgemment à l'heure où la Commission
européenne a vraisemblablement enterré
ce projet et donc c'est une des demandes
que nous formulons pour transformer en
profondeur de la cave au grenier les
règles éthiques au sein des institutions
européennes Véronique trilay Lenoir
devrait démissionner vous êtes d'accord
avec ce lien de dire Manon Aubry la
vice-présidente Eva Kylie je suis
d'accord avec tout ce qu'a dit madame
Aubry y compris concernant la nécessité
d'une commission d'enquête
assortie probablement de réglementation
plus forte sur la transparence des liens
entre les parlementaires et les groupes
d'influence qui doivent normalement je
le croyais obligatoire mais j'ai appris
que c'était seulement sur la base du
volontariat être déclaré dans un
registre ce registre doit être rendu
obligatoire pour les députés européens
et aussi comme le montre cette sinistre
à faire pour des députés qui ne sont
plus en poste mais qui continue à avoir
des entrées au Parlement et donc
semblent-ils la possibilité
d'instrumentaliser d'influencer voire
d'acheter des personnels des
institutions européennes Patrick
martin-geniès qui a une culture de
l'impunité au Parlement européen je ne
dirais pas qu'il y a une culture de
l'impunité mais c'est vrai que c'est le
Parlement européen et la Commission
européenne Bruxelles de façon générale
si je peux me permettre d'utiliser cette
expression c'est un laboratoire à ciel
ouvert du lobbying des groupes de
pression il y a des dizaines des
centaines de groupes de pression à
Bruxelles et ces dernières années
effectivement s'est aperçu qu'il pouvait
y avoir quelques dérives parce que moi
j'apprenais en préparant cette émission
que certains présidents d'intergroupent
des groupes non-officiels du Parlement
européen doivent déclarer les avantages
qu'ils reçoivent parfois financiers et
en nature de la foi de la part de
certains groupes de pression ça c'est
inacceptable ceci dit les institutions
ont fait un progrès ces dernières années
il vient d'être évoqué un registre de
transparence qui s'impose aux
institutions européennes notamment la
Commission et le Parlement européen mais
manifestement ça ne suffit pas parce que
on voit bien que certains parlementaires
sont très proches par exemple un
parlementaire peut avoir un secrétariat
qui est payé par un groupe de pression
et ça pour moi ce n'est pas acceptable
parce que ça rend ce député dépendant
d'un groupe de pression on va y revenir
d'ailleurs maintenant au brillant je
sais que vous devez nous quitter dans
dans pas très longtemps un mot peut-être
sur ces travaux sur la délivrance de
visa et des visites prévues donc pour
justement les katariens est-ce qu'ils
sont suspendus ces travaux parce que ça
devait être une discussion me
semble-t-il que de faciliter l'obtention
de ces visas
en effet ce vote était prévu pour se
tenir place cette semaine je crois que à
l'heure où le Qatar a infiltré au plus
haut niveau les institutions européennes
l'urgence n'est pas à faciliter l'accès
des visas des Cathares et ceux d'autant
plus qu'on sait aperçu que le vote qui
s'est tenu en commission Libé qui est la
commission qui était en charge de ce
dossier c'est tenu en réalité avec
quatre membres qui ne faisaient pas
partie de cette commission et qui sont
des noms cités mis en cause dans cette
affaire donc on peut avoir des doutes
sur la manière dont se vote c'est
dérouler en commission raison pour
laquelle il a été suspendu en session
plénière et je crois que c'est une bonne
chose et qu'il y avait un consensus
général sur le sujet je note aussi que
nous étions le seul groupe à nous être
opposés au moment de la Commission à
cette libéralisation des visas qui prend
forcément une autre tournure au vu du
contexte Véronique triele noir il faut
donc suspendre ses autorisations c'est
facilitation c'est facilité de visa pour
les katariens
il faut les suspendre le temps que toute
la lumière soit faite sur les pressions
qui ont pu exister il faut laisser se
faire une enquête qui n'en est
manifestement cassé des buts et aussi
au-delà de la simple affaire du Qatar
regarder comment les institutions
européennes et en particulier le
Parlement peuvent se protéger contre des
attaques extérieures et éviter de
laisser grandir en elle le cancer de la
corruption qui est vraiment le pire
qu'il puisse arriver à une démocratie
merci Manon Andréa je vous remercie
parce que je sais que vous devez nous
quitter merci d'avoir été avec nous en
tout cas pendant ce petit quart d'heure
dans le débat David Rigoulet rose
Véronique tri le nom a des mots quand
même très fort attaque de la démocratie
ce sont aussi les mots de Roberta
mezzola est-ce que des pays comme le
Qatar sont habiles c'est-à-dire qu'ils
savent finalement que l'Europe est
insuffisamment protégée donc ils
arrivent à trouver les coins par
lesquels on peut pénétrer
effectivement des défaillances qui ont
été soulevées par les héros députés il y
a au niveau de Bruxelles il y a eu des
efforts qui ont été faits vous le
soulignez parce que aujourd'hui par
exemple on sait qu'il y a près de 20 000
lobbies officiellement enregistrés donc
c'est
enregistrés alors ce n'est pas les états
c'est les lobbys entreprises
effectivement européen transparence mais
oui
les pays aussi les pays bah oui oui à
travers des associations
semi diplomatique voilà parce que vous
avez par exemple des ONG qui peuvent
être de relais aussi qui sont financés
et qui peuvent relayer éventuellement
des stratégies du flux d'influence
d'ailleurs là il y en a deux justement
le paradoxe c'est son intitulé
puisqu'elle est censée être lutter
contre lutter contre l'impunité donc
c'est vrai qu'il y a quelque chose
ONG pour justement apparaître
normalement si je peux me permettre
d'abord elles doivent être enregistrées
vous venez de le dire premièrement mais
elle doit souscrire à un code de bonne
conduite avec des
manifestement ne suffit pas parce qu'il
peut y avoir des dérives et c'est en
cela ou c'était pas suffisant parce que
finalement il n'y a pas assez de
contrôle il y a un registre de
transparence les députés viennent de le
dire vous aussi mais ce registre n'est
pas suffisamment contraignant oui alors
en fait il est beaucoup pour les
commissaires c'est-à-dire pour toute la
structure de l'exécutif Bruxelles loi il
est pour les ce qu'on appelle les postes
importants en fait au niveau des
parlementaires mais pas pour le
parlementaire
de base et d'ailleurs il y a même à
défaut on dit que les lobbies peuvent
rencontrer les parlementaires en dehors
des couloirs officiels c'est un
euphémisme pour dire que finalement
n'importe quel type de contact peut être
effectivement
réalisé en dehors de toute exigence
éthique personnelle sauf que là nous
avons à une vice-présidente
parce que ça ça met en cause une
personne qui normalement règlement a
quand même des obligations Véronique
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
tout de même au Parlement européen c'est
plutôt l'impunité qui règne c'est-à-dire
que les députés n'ont pas vraiment de
compte à rendre
non je ne suis pas tout à fait d'accord
d'abord dire qu'on Parlement européen
l'immense majorité des euros députés
travaillent en conscience et dans
l'intérêt collectif ce à quoi nous avons
à faire là c'est un groupe mafieux
osons le mot accusé de corruption
c'est-à-dire au pénal mais je suis
d'accord avec Monsieur Rigoulet pour
dire que probablement en amont la racine
du mal corruption commence probablement
par du trafic d'influence et le trafic
d'influence doit se combattre en
augmentant les actions contre les
groupes de pression oui les eurodéputés
sont autorisés à rencontrer des groupes
d'influences en dehors du Parlement
qu'il le soit me paraît normal que ça ne
soit pas déclaré me paraît totalement
injustifiée de la même manière
commission l'organisation éthique que
nous appelons nos vœux et pas seulement
de groupes de Martine de Manon Aubry
notre groupe également cette autorité
que nous appelons nos vœux elle doit
pouvoir contrôler elle doit pouvoir
avoir accès aux déclarations publiques
d'intérêt que nous donnons elle doit
pouvoir collaborer avec d'autres
organisations donc ne soyons pas trop
défaitiste il y a une marge de manœuvre
pour améliorer les choses et essayer de
limiter ce type de scandale Patrick
martin-genier on avait l'impression que
Ursula van derlion dans son agenda
lorsque il est arrivé c'était justement
aussi de renforcer la lutte contre la
corruption de mettre en place me
semble-t-il une autorité qui allait
justement superviser l'éthique pourquoi
ne l'a-t-elle pas fait je pense que ce
n'était peut-être pas la priorité de
l'agenda il y a eu la guerre en Ukraine
il y a eu la covid donc tout cela a
bousculé du jour de l'Europe et
d'ailleurs je crois savoir que ce matin
madame monsieur Lafont Darline la
présidente de la commission a relancé ce
débat sur une charte d'éthique sur une
déontologie peut-être créer un
déontologue commun à l'ensemble des
institutions c'est très important
effectivement de le faire parce qu'on ne
peut pas se permettre je dirais que la
Commission elle-même n'a pas été à
l'abri de petites soupçons de corruption
ou d'acte de mauvaise gouvernance on
peut dire rappelez-vous l'ancien
président de la Commission européenne
quelques mois après être parti avait été
recruté dans une grande banque
internationale britannique je crois même
si ça n'avait rien illégal et bien ça
jette une ombre en quelque sorte sur
effectivement la probité de certaines
personnes donc il faut faire extrêmement
attention évidemment il y a le principe
de présomption d'innocence aussi que
Madame Kaeli puisse se défendre c'est
très important de le souligner mais il y
a ce qu'on appelle la Russie à Bruxelles
la théorie des apparences c'est à dire
qu'on doit être au-dessus de tout
soupçon et là c'est important pourquoi
parce que les institutions européennes
sont l'objet comme cela vient d'être dit
de deux attaques et l'Europe aujourd'hui
n'a bien évidemment pas besoin de cela
alors justement il y en a un qui se
frotte les mains si je puis dire c'est
tout de même Victor Orban qui a tweeté
aujourd'hui en réagissant à ce scandale
justement à Bruxelles sont tweet en fait
se moquent de ce scandale il dit bonjour
Parlement européen vous le voyez là à
l'écran sont tweet ils disent le
Parlement européen est concerné par la
corruption en Hongrie il s'est réjouit
parce que finalement aujourd'hui il y a
une partie de bras de fer vous le savez
entre le entre Bruxelles entre la
Commission européenne et la Hongrie pour
justement une affaire de corruption
Véronique trial le noir c'est tout de
même très embarrassant pour l'Europe que
ça tombe à un moment où il y a une
procédure nouvelle d'ailleurs une
procédure un instrument de
conditionnalité justement avec la
Hongrie en ce moment qui est d'ailleurs
confirmé puisqu'il y a un gel donc d'une
partie des des fonds qui sont alloués à
la Hongrie est-ce que ce n'est pas très
embarrassant ce qui se passe parce que
finalement elle perd en crédibilité dans
son combat contre la corruption
ce qui se passe est très embarrassant
mais ce que dit Monsieur urban est
inattendable la corruption en Hongrie
c'est une corruption d'État ici nous
avons affaire à une commune à une
correction qui touche
alors excusez-moi mais j'ai été con on
vous entend Véronique Triel vous pouvez
poursuivre j'en étais à dire que ceux
qui touche le Parlement européen c'est
une corruption menée par quelques
individus j'espère qu'on en dit dans
différents le moins possible mais ça
n'est pas une corruption de
l'institution dans son ensemble comme la
corruption de Orban est une corruption
d'État donc je n'entends pas cet
argument néanmoins il est bien évident
que ce scandale touche le Parlement
européen ce que j'espère c'est que loin
d'affaiblir les institutions européennes
elle va d'abord affaiblir les coupables
c'est-à-dire le Qatar et les députés
assistants ONG qui se sont livrés à de
tels infamies et que nous au Parlement
européen nous aurons des réactions
collectives et solidaires pour
David Rigoulet rose pour rebondir sur ce
que vient de dire Véronique trailer le
noir comment est-ce qu'effectivement le
Qatar peut véritablement payer
aujourd'hui c'est le pays haute du
Mondial on sait que vraiment cette
semaine est importante puisqu'il y a
demi-finale finale quel impact
finalement est-ce qu'on va assister une
sorte de tournant dans les relations
véritables entre le Qatar et l'Union
européenne on peut dire ça bah là pour
l'instant c'est un problème surtout pour
les institutions européennes
d'abord on le voit bien c'est un choc
pour tout le monde et il s'agit pas du
jeter le tout l'eau propre sur
l'ensemble des députés ce serait ce
serait injuste même si l'affaire est
grave d'ailleurs je note quand même
qu'il y a eu fin 2019 un amendement qui
était proposé justement pour renforcer
la réglementation des acteurs clés du
processus législatif pour éviter
justement les parasitages et que ça et
que ça avait été salué par l'OMG
transparente si internationale qui
regrettait quand même que ça ne concerne
pas à l'époque le les députés justement
et là on touche au problème qui se pose
aussi dans le cadre de cette affaire
maintenant pour ce qui est du Qatar le
Qatar a considéré que dans le cas de de
du Mondial il faisait l'objet d'un
nouveau Catard bashing et en disant que
finalement il y avait une stigmatisation
de de l'organisateur au moment où il y
avait le déroulement de l'opération
enfin de justement des matchs alors que
finalement la vraie question elle était
largement en amont effectivement la
vraie question elle était au moment de
l'officialisation de la candidature du
Qatar donc aujourd'hui il y a eu le
Qatar joue un peu sur ce Regis en disant
que finalement il y a de la part de ceux
qui le stigmatise une forme
d'instrumentalisation avec d'autres
dessins pierre Bénazet vous nous avez
rejoint notre correspondant à Bruxelles
vous avez un peu vécu ce week-end plein
de rebondissements avec avec ce scandale
on parlait justement de Victor Orban
est-ce que finalement c'est pas un vrai
problème que l'Europe par exemple l'air
en ce moment alors qu'elle est en pleine
procédure justement avec la Hongrie
ce qu'il y a c'est qu'évidemment ça se
passe pas sur le même plan que les
procédures avec la Hongrie les skis ce
que Victor urban est-ce que le fidèle en
général utilise comme argument
aujourd'hui dévoyé comme on l'a vu en se
moquant de ces affaires de corruption en
train du Parlement européen c'est le
fait que au sein même du Parlement il y
a des groupes extrêmement importants et
majoritaires qui luttent contre la
corruption et qui depuis des années
depuis quasiment depuis le début de la
deuxième vie politique de Victor Hormann
depuis son retour en 2010 dans les rênes
sur son retour aux commandes en 2010
beaucoup de groupes se sont et en
particulier au sein du groupe socialiste
les CD beaucoup de groupes se sont pris
d'intérêt pour le dossier de l'État de
droit en Hongrie on va essayer de
défendre la liberté de la presse en
Hongrie essayer de défendre l'État de
droit et surtout l'indépendance de la
justice en Hongrie et c'est ça
évidemment que
Orban que le fidèle utilise aujourd'hui
pour se moquer du Parlement européen
l'aspect l'aspect conditionnalité c'est
à dire cette nouvelle instrument qu'on a
mis en place lorsqu'on a négocié les
actuels perspectives financières c'est à
dire le budget plus réaluel l'Union
européenne cette fonctionnalité là elle
a été trouvée par les 27 par les États
membres c'est une conditionnalité qui
est relative au mode de dépenses donc le
fait qu'on bloque la perspective de
bloquer les fonds structurelles
c'est-à-dire le budget régulier de
l'Union européenne de bloquer aussi la
partie majare du plan de relance ça
c'est du ressort des 27 évidemment le
Parlement européen a poussé beaucoup la
Commission européenne à activer cet
outil on dit en grande partie la
Commission européenne a pris cette
décision à cause des pressions
politiques du Parlement européen c'est
son rôle et c'est l'honneur du Parlement
européen en l'occurrence donc le
Parlement européen au contraire approuvé
qu'il était capable d'agir et de pousser
politiquement Patrick
il a poussé et
tout en son honneur c'est ce que dit
Pierre Benazet mais en même temps
aujourd'hui il est entaché par ce
scandale en plein bras de fer avec la
Hongrie bien sûr l'occasion est trop
belle pour Victor Aubagne on sait que
lui c'est un état libéral il y a des
graves soupçons de corruption dans
l'utilisation des fonds structures de
structurelles ce n'est plus un état qui
respecte les valeurs européennes qui
s'agissent de la Justice de la presse de
des droits de la communauté LGBT tout ça
c'est foulée au pied et puis
effectivement et bien il en profite
parce que le Parlement européen vous
l'avez dit c'est tout à son honneur
défend l'état droit en gris et en
Pologne également il n'en demeure pas
moins qu'il ne faut pas minimiser ce
séisme politique que cela représente je
rappellerai deux choses premièrement il
s'agit d'une vice-présidente quand même
du Parlement européen qui est donc une
position éminente qui va donc présider
des séances lorsque la présidente ne le
fait pas premièrement deuxièmement quand
même cette inédit depuis 1979 c'est une
élue socialiste
membre du pazooc Parti socialiste grec
et donc c'est la première fois alors il
y a eu plusieurs scandales on a eu vous
rappelez vous ça touche la droite
l'extrême droite les emplois fictifs les
menaces enfin les détournements d'argent
public et maintenant ça touche le groupe
socialiste donc le danger aujourd'hui
même si je suis d'accord pour dire que
80% enfin l'immense majorité des députés
sont au-dessus de tout soupçon il en
devenant séisme considérable pourquoi
parce que ça touche finalement un groupe
politique très très important
politique c'est ce que vous dites c'est
ce que fait des risques de récupération
en Europe mais également du côté de la
droite et de l'extrême droite qui va
pouvoir tirer également regarder il n'y
a pas de nous que nous qui sommes
soupçonnés regardez le groupe socialiste
elle est également d'où la réaction
extrêmement rapide de madame mezzola qui
a décidé et de Parlement de suspendre
cette personne il faut effectivement
qu'il n'y ait plus de pouvoir quant à
démissionné de ses fonctions c'est
quelque chose qui regarde le pazooc et
cette personne en particulier alors
justement en tout cas pierre bennez qui
sera intéressant de le redire c'est que
c'est la police de Bruxelles qui s'est
qui a lancé une en sont pas vraiment les
institutions européennes c'est vraiment
au niveau pénal que ça se passe avec la
police de Bruxelles d'où un peu la
surprise j'imagine oui effectivement
même si et on a entendu Roberta
messsalla le dire tout à l'heure à la
tribune à Strasbourg les services du
Parlement européen collabore avec la
police judiciaire belge depuis quasiment
apparemment le début de cette enquête
qui a commencé il y a un peu plus de 4
mois donc les services du Parlement
européen et la police judiciaire belge
le juge d'instruction Michel cllaise et
son nom sont en lien avec les services
de Roberta metzola tout ça s'est passé
sous embargo comme on dit au sein de la
police belge c'est-à-dire que les actes
du jeu d'instruction n'ont pas été
versés dans les dossiers électroniques
bref il y a eu une entente directe entre
le Parlement européen et les enquêteurs
belges il y a d'ailleurs eu des enquêtes
qui ont été menées simultanément en
Grèce et en Italie on a vu deux
arrestations qui sont survenus en très
rapidement et puis il y a eu aussi un
édifice à plusieurs étages les
enquêteurs belges eux-mêmes ont été
surpris par la réussite en quelque sorte
de leur premier coup de filet de
vendredi matin puisque c'est grâce à ce
qu'ils ont trouvé vendredi matin grâce
au fait qu'il y a eu un flagrant délire
avec de l'argent liquide saisi chez des
proches de Eva kylique qu'ils ont pu
ainsi aller perquisitionner à son
domicile à elle vendredi soir et
l'arrêter plus de 12 heures après avoir
arrêté plus de 10 heures après avoir
arrêté son compagnon Francesco Giorgi le
matin dans cette affaire et puis il y a
eu aussi les perquisitions qui ont eu
lieu aujourd'hui au Parlement européen
ou la police belge a saisi du matériel
informatique qui avait été mis sous
scellé ce week-end ces matériels ce
matériel informatique appartenaient à
des assistants tous interpellaient le
gel de leur batailler informatique avait
été effectué dès vendredi par les
services du Parlement c'était donc prévu
à l'avance puis je voudrais juste
ajouter un point c'est la première fois
que le groupe socialiste est ainsi dans
la tourmente puisque c'est une
commissaire socialiste qui avait fait
Edith Cresson en l'occurrence qui avait
fait chuter la commission sans terre
commissaire un peu plus de 23 ans
maintenant c'était une commissaire
allemande de la commission Center et
rappelons une chose c'est que si cette
commission avait démissionné madame
récréation avait été blanchi par la
justice donc si vous voulez dire c'est
que c'est pas la première fois que ça
arrive en tout cas qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire allez-y
je voulais juste dire que c'était le pas
la première fois que le groupe
socialiste était saisi de tels très
meurt qui le secret en interne c'est
vrai que même si les socialistes ont
beaucoup ont fait partie très souvent
des commissions ont beaucoup poussé pour
les registres de transparence du
Parlement européen et de l'Union
européenne en général ils ne sont pas
ils n'étaient pas indemnes
sur cette affaire enfin on a
l'impression que c'est tout un système
en plus effectivement il y a eu des
arrestations en Italie enfin il y en a
eu un certain nombre est-ce que et puis
de l'argent liquide alors maintenant on
parle d'un million je sais pas très bien
mais est-ce que
ça vous paraît assez logique en fait en
fait il y a eu quoi une traçabilité il y
a eu enfin c'est quand même incroyable
ce qu'elle puisse passer
il y a eu une manifestement une enquête
qui a été bien menée puisque elle a
débouché sur des arrestations avec un
flagrant délit donc oui il y avait sans
doute une traçabilité moi j'ai pas tous
les éléments je peux me permettre une
enquête qui avait commencé dès cet été
au mois d'aoûtant traçabilité avec des
écoutes et cetera on ne débarque pas
chez quelqu'un comme ça sans avoir fait
une enquête préalable en sachant qu'il y
aurait des centaines de milliers d'euros
dans une sacoche donc c'est une enquête
qui dure effectivement par la justice
belge depuis plusieurs mois
c'est ce que vous dites il y avait une
enquête en fait qui existait depuis un
moment côté justice belge mais personne
n'était vraiment au courant au sein du
Parlement européen
au niveau du
député lambda que je suis au Parlement
européen non je crois qu'il faut ici
saluer le travail de la justice belge en
lien avec les services du Parlement
européen et dans notre groupe politique
nous sommes déterminés si nécessaire et
sera probablement le cas à prêter main
forte à la poursuite des investigations
qui sont annoncées je voudrais également
dire que ça me paraît extrêmement
dangereux de politiser ce type de débat
en termes de qui a fait quoi dans tel et
telle groupe nous avons à faire ici un
réseau mafieux d'individus qui échappe à
toutes les règles à toutes les lois y
compris celle de leur groupe politique
et je suis d'autant plus à l'aise pour
le dire que ça n'est pas
un groupe politique alors ce que vous
proposez en tout cas c'est qu'il y ait
tout de même une institution en interne
qui soit une sorte de garde-fou
justement c'est ça que vous proposez
nous proposons une espèce d'équivalent
de ce que la France a mis en place avec
la Haute Autorité de la transparence de
la vie publique c'est-à-dire une
organisation
inter-institutionnelle par le mot
européen et Commission européenne qui
puisse entendre les lanceurs d'alerte
répondre au lanceur d'alerte par des
enquêtes qui commenceront par la
consultation des déclarations d'intérêt
de chacun la consultation d'un registre
qui devra être comme je l'ai dit
obligatoire et complet et puis des
enquêtes qui seront menées en lien avec
d'autres organisations nationales comme
par exemple chez nous la Haute Autorité
à la transparence de la vie publique ou
européenne comme l'Office européen de
lutte contre la fraude donc il nous faut
c'est souvent comme ça au sein de
l'Union européenne non pas créé de
nouveaux outils et ajouter une couche au
millefeuille mais coordonnées des outils
qui existent et qui me semblent-ils
devraient pouvoir réagir plus en amont
plus vite faire en quelque sorte de la
prévention en repérant très vite les
liens d'intérêt et les influences
éventuelles qui sont néfastes et
risquent de devenir encore plus Patrick
génie donc plutôt une coordination de
structures déjà existantes plutôt que la
mise en place que disait Manon Aubry me
semble-t-il d'une autorité indépendante
au sein des institutions
il en faut la Haute autorité pour la vie
publique en France on a bien vu que ce
n'était pas suffisant la preuve c'est
que des ministres des missions
régulièrement parce qu'ils ont oublié de
déclarer une partie de leur patrimoine
moi je voudrais poser une question à
Madame la Députée je voudrais savoir par
exemple à l'Assemblée nationale
nous avons ce qu'on appelle un
déontologue de l'Assemblée nationale je
m'étonne que ce ne soit pas d'ores et
déjà le cas au Parlement européen est-ce
qu'il existe à déontologue qui va
éventuellement vérifier et bien le train
de vie les dépenses des parlementaires
voilà c'est quelque chose très important
parce que une haute autorité l'office de
lutte anti fraude c'est très bien est-ce
qu'il y a un déontologue au sein du
Parlement européen ou est-ce qu'il ne
faut pas en créer un ce serait pas un
millefeuille supplémentaire ce serait
peut-être un garde-fou tout à fait
salutaire
c'est une bonne suggestion je ne sache
pas qu'il y en ait un et la différence
que je vois entre
la déclaration à la Haute Autorité de la
vie publique française que je déclare et
lien d'intérêt européen c'est l'absence
d'une déclaration du patrimoine en amont
et en aval du mandat ce qui par une
substraction simple permettrait de
connaître un éventuel enrichissement ou
de pister un éventuel blanchiment pour
répondre à votre question précise je
trouve que c'est une bonne idée je n'ai
pas dit qu'il ne fallait pas créer comme
l'a dit Manon Aubry une haute autorité à
la transparence mais j'ai dit qu'il
fallait aussi coordonner des
organisations qui ne sont peut-être pas
suffisamment bien Benazet justement vous
pouvez réagir sur une quels sont les
garde-fous il faut de toute façon plus
de peut-être plus de transparence
la transparence elle existe un petit peu
tout à l'heure on a entendu Roberta
metzella la présidente du Parlement
européen demandé proposer une réforme
assez large qui permettrait par exemple
de savoir exactement qui pénètre dans
les locaux du Parlement européen que ça
soit à Strasbourg à Luxembourg ou à
Bruxelles en l'occurrence qui peut
rentrer et discuter avec les députés
enfin il y a pas de contrôle
n'importe qui ne rentre plus c'est
devenu extrêmement compliqué c'est un
peu la réaction épidermique des
institutions de ce type dès qu'elles ont
l'impression qu'elles ont du pouvoir
elles se crée des agents de sécurité et
des contrôles sécurité extérieurs les
plus longs possibles pour créer des
files d'attente aux portes des bâtiments
c'est devenu assez compliqué d'entrer
dans le Parlement européen mais on peut
sacréditer si on est un journaliste par
exemple ou si on est membre d'un lobby à
crédité il faut se présenter dans un
registre et demander des cartes
d'accréditation
euh ce que sous-entendais robertament
cela tout à l'heure c'est que
contrôler qui entre dans le Parlement
européen ça veut ça veut dire faire des
meilleures listes de lobby puisque élite
évident que tous les députés que tous
les citoyens européens et des lobbies
étrangers aussi peuvent avoir accès à
des députés européens il est clair que
pour les citoyens européens c'est un
droit immédiat surtout si c'est dans la
circonscription par exemple mais les
élus européens doivent avoir accès à des
informations pour savoir comment faire
les lois qui lui ont proposé et puis il
y a aussi des lobbys transnationaux des
lobbies étrangers qui sont tous
enregistrés mais puis quelquefois pas
très bien et on sait que ce registre des
lobbies par exemple a beaucoup de
défauts parce que il y a des il y a des
trous dans la raquette estimons ici de
plusieurs ONG estime qu'il faudrait
réformer ce registre que il est possible
que un cinquième ou un dixième des
lobbyistes présents à Bruxelles ne soit
absolument pas enregistré dans d'autres
registres dans le registre en question
donc en fait Véronique il faudrait une
quoi une grande réforme aujourd'hui
au sein des institutions européennes
pour qui est plus de garanties de
transparence pour que il y ait plus de
check comme on peut dire en anglais plus
de contrôle oui enfin je voudrais quand
même revenir sur ce qui a été
sous-entendu non on ne rentre pas au
Parlement européen comme dans un moulin
il faut avoir
bien dit
je voudrais que je voulais quand même
clarifier cela et dire également ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure quand vous
rencontrez Nick trier le noir au
Parlement européen c'est immédiatement
enregistré dans le registre prévu à cet
effet dans ma naïveté je pensais que
cette démarche était obligatoire en
réalité elle ne l'est pas donc c'est une
première raison pour qu'il y ait des
trous dans la requête il faut rendre les
rencontres avec les euros députés et
tous les groupes d'influence
transparents
c'est à dire obligatoirement enregistré
y compris et peut-être surtout quand ils
ont lieu en dehors de l'enceinte du
Parlement pour par exemple ce qui peut
s'apparenter à des petits déjeuners ou à
des dîners juste pour ajouter que je
suis médecin et que dans le monde de la
santé nous avons connu malheureusement
suffisamment de crise sanitaire et de
scandale sanitaire pour que
l'organisation ait été prévue lorsque je
reçois une compensation même sous forme
d'un café d'un industriel de la santé
c'est immédiatement rendu public sur un
site prévu à cet effet c'est pareil à la
FD et américaine je trouve que c'est
plutôt simple c'est plutôt simple Martin
genièvre
tout à fait raison moi je suis allé au
Parlement européen il y a pas longtemps
je peux vous dire que c'est extrêmement
difficile de rentrer au Parlement c'est
bien qu'un aéroport
donc c'est plus difficile
de cela et je peux vous dire que c'est
vrai qu'il y a une grande exigence sur
l'utilisation de l'argent public
notamment sur les repas un
parlementaires ne peut pas avoir de
privilèges par rapport à des repas mais
il n'en demeure pas moins que il y a des
trous dans la raquette parce que quand
vous faites un rapporteur fait un
rapport au Parlement européen il
rencontre de multiples groupes de
pressions et donc il va dire
effectivement qu'il a rencontré des
groupes de pression et on ne sait pas
jusqu'où ce groupe de pression peut
influencer le rapport du parlementaire
donc il y a certainement effectivement
des efforts à faire David rigoléro pour
terminer alors est-ce que la relation
avec le Qatar va changer avec ce
scandale bah ça va certainement
effectivement impliqué un réajustement
des relations on a beaucoup parlé des
débats justement de le problème de
l'éthique ce sera pas forcément
uniquement avec le Qatar d'ailleurs ça
pourra la question pourra se poser avec
d'autres pétromanarchies d'ailleurs la
question de la libéralisation du visage
concernait pas que le Qatar il y avait
le Koweït etc donc de manière générale
oui il y aura effectivement une
réflexion qui va être menée puisque
transparent aussi internationale ont
évoqué les possibilités justement de de
renforcement il constate qu'il y avait
quand même de son point de vue une
absence de contrôle et qu'il faudrait
créer un organisme d'éthique indépendant
voilà donc ça tout le monde revient
finalement à cette organisme mais bon
concrètement les Européens apportent du
gaz du Qatar donc il y a du business
donc à partir du moment où il y a du
business il faut que le contrôle soit
d'autant plus important j'imagine c'est
probablement ce qui va être mis en place
c'est effectivement un renforcement des
des procédures de contrôle pour éviter
ce type de dérive business dans la
transparence business dans la
transparence vous voulez conclure pierre
Benazet business transparence dit
Patrick Martin génie ma femme c'est ce
que réclame Robert ramène cela c'est ce
que réclame sous la femme de la hyène
tout en sachant que plusieurs députés
européens dont Manon Aubry dont on est
auquel nom de tout à l'heure estime que
ce sont des promesses qui ont été faites
sans jamais qu'il y ait concrétisation
depuis plusieurs années tout est une
question de vision politique
en l'occurrence merci Pierre Benazet
merci beaucoup à vous Véronique trier
Lenoir d'avoir été avec nous merci à
Manon Aubry qui était avec nous au début
de cette émission merci David
rigouléraux et merci beaucoup à vous
Patrick Martin génie merci à vous tous
de nous avoir suivi et restez avec nous
sur France 24